100k 150k years to then becoming
sort of double that 300k 400k plus
pillars what
what changed in their day-to-day from
when they were 150k builders to
that people want to know that it's what
i've talked about already right
it's the belief in how you win
this person the previous year
right had a performance that was
um disappointing so so this person spent
the christmas break
trying to understand me trying to
uncover what what it is that would make
a difference in their market
and key difference was working with
better commitment
by february like i can't work with you
until unless you retain because i've got
such a full desk
this demonstrated their credibility
everybody wanted to work with this
person
that person went from 300 that year the
previous year
to 1.1 million u.s a complete difference
and that difference was because of
understanding how that how would they
win in their market and the way that
we would win was great commitment uh and
which is working on retain
a very clear example is it's um
there will be different nuances but
understand it and then commit to it